So we know, this is the fourth power. 3 to the 4th equals 81. And this form is
considered to be exponential form. Now, another new form that we're going to
talk about is logarithmic form. Log form involves a logarithm, and it's just
another way of writing this equation. The key idea for a logarithm is that its
base will be the same base in the equation above. So if we have 3 to the fourth
equals 81, then we'll have log with a base of 3 set equal to 4. The answer to a
logarithm is an exponent. Meaning if I take the log base 3 of some number, I'll
get 4. Now it turns out that that number has to be 81. So we read this
statement as log base 3 of 81 equals 4. We're asking ourselves, what's the
exponent that we need to raise a base of 3 to, to get 81? Well, that exponent
is 4. When we take the logarithm of any number, we'll always get an exponent.
We use logarithms as a way to undo or reverse raising a number to a power. For
example, if we had this exponential form, we can also write it in logarithmic
form. This base becomes the base of our logarithm. So, we'll have log base two
of sum number equals 3, the exponent. We know that this number must be 8, since
2 raised to the third power equals 8. The log base 2 of 8 is the exponent that
we need to raise 2 to in order to get 8. So, in this case, log base 2 of 8
equals 3. In general, when we have something written in exponential form with a
base raised to an exponent equal to a number, we can rewrite this in
logarithmic form. We can make the base be the base of our logarithm, the number
is the argument for a logarithm and the answer is the exponent. So log with
base b of some number always will give us an exponent. I think the key idea in
any of these situations is that the log of a number results in an exponent. The
same was true for this example.